Well, I, I was there,
I went to Stockholm twice in Oslo
twice and Helsinki twice and, and,
and Copenhagen once in the last month.
And I spent quite a bit of
a lot of interviews, um,
and a lot of discussion about
the so called gender paradox.
Now it's a very interesting thing cause
it's really put their tails into not in
Scandinavia. And,
and that makes sense because
the Scandinavians are
going to have to deal with
this first because they've
gone the farthest down the
road for like making their
society gender equal. Explain
that to people. I will. I will.
Okay. So,
so imagine first of all that there's
two kinds of equality that you might
pursue.
One would be equality of opportunity and
so that would mean that um, you know,
there's, there's wide range of talent
across people regardless of their type,
whatever that might be. Sex,
gender, race, ethnicity,
there's, there's talent
distributed everywhere.
And it's a kind of a truism.
And I would say a truism of
the West in the deepest sense,
that each of the individuals within
those groups should be put in a position
where they, their talents are, they're
encouraged to manifest those talents,
partly because that would be good for
them spiritually and psychologically,
but also because that would be of
obvious benefit to the community, right?
I mean, talents rare, which
people don't understand.
There's lots of different
kinds of talent, but it's,
but in each domain it's rare.
And so it's to everyone's benefit to
exploit talented people to the maximum
possible degree. So even
if you're just selfish,
you want to push for equality
of opportunity because
the more talented people
there are out there, the more cool stuff
you get to have. And hopefully the,
the more diverse and
interesting your life is. So,
so you can pursue equality
of opportunity, um,
policies and the
Scandinavians have done that,
especially trying to knock down
barriers for women in the workplace.
And by all accounts, by
all standard theories,
the Scandinavian countries in places
like, like ho, like the Netherlands,
Canada to to a slightly lesser
degree, um, have done, uh,
have gone farther than any other
countries in pursuing those, um,
policies. Okay. And, and,
and part of the consequence of that is
that some of the differences between men
and women have been minimized.
So obviously there's far more women in
the workplace and there were 40 years ago
and in many occupations there's
actually dominance by women.
There's dominance in the universities,
there's dominance in
the healthcare fields.
And so women have poured
into the workplace.
And hypothetically there's problems with
that because it's put a lot of stress
on family structure. But
hypothetically, that's for the best.
And because it gives people a broader
range of choices and it gives everyone
access to more talent. So, and then
also if you look around the world,
you see that one of
the best predictors of,
of the probability of economic development
in developing countries is their
attitude is the attitude in those
countries towards equal rights for women.
And it looks causal.
The more positively the country
is predisposed to female rights,
the more likely they are
to develop economically.
And maybe that's because that indicates
that they're open to new ideas or
something like that or open
to transformation. So, okay,
so that's one kind of equality.
Open up the playing field so that
everybody has a chance to compete and
cooperate and land and
land where they will.
But then the other kind of equality
is equality of outcome. So,
and that's often described as
equity in today's language.
And so the ultimate equity
utopia would be take every job,
every conceivable kind of job,
and then stratify that by
every conceivable level of
authority within every job
and then ensure that every single category
of person is represented in precise
proportion to their, to their
prevalence in the population.
So every job should be 50% women and
50% man and say 13% non Western ethnic
minority and whatever that happens to be.
And then you could break that
down and so and otherwise,
there's evidence of
systemic prejudice. Okay.
Now first thing to say about
that is that's impossible.
And the reason it's impossible is because
there's no limit to the number of ways
that you can categorize people
into groups. So you know, you,
you know about sex and ethnicity and
race, maybe those are the obvious ones,
but now you have gender and then
you have ethnicity and you know,
and then there's attractiveness and
intelligence and temperament and,
and height and age and, and, and
socioeconomic background. And I mean,
let's say there's 20 but
there's a lot more than that.
There's no possible way that you could
ever regulate a society so tightly that
every single one of those groups was
equally represented in every single one of
those occupations at every single level
of the hierarchy that concentrate on the
significant ones, men and women and race.
But who's to say those are the
significant ones? That's the other thing.
It isn't even obvious that they are
because I would say that like a more
significant one is cognitive ability
because that's a way bigger predictor of
longterm life success than sex or race.
So I don't even think that
we've necessarily identified
the canonical groups.
We've just decided that gender and race
are the, maybe they're the most obvious.
Right.
But isn't there a problem is that people
don't [inaudible] what they don't do is
they don't take in, in terms of cognitive
ability, they don't get on a team.
They don't get on like there's people
that are sexist. Yeah. But there's,
it's very rare that someone is elitist
in terms of their cognitive ability.
Well, hard to say Joe.
I mean I think one of the reasons that
elite is prejudiced is a better word.
I don't know. I mean you
could be right, but look,
I think one of the
reasons that like if you,
here's something that's kind of cute.
It makes sense now that I'm thinking
about it. Of course they are. Well,
there's one thing that's quite peculiar
about the United States in that regard
is like most working
class people, let's say,
are far more irritated with the
intellectual elite than they are with the
wealthy elite.
And that's because they think they
could become wealthy and they could,
but they don't think they could
become part of the intellectual elite.
And it isn't obvious to me
that the intellectual elite,
so those would be the liberal left
leaning types that dominate the media and
academia are particularly,
um, positive in their,
in their attitudes towards the
typical working class person.
I think they're prejudiced and elitist.
I do believe that that's the case.
And I think there are also, um,
what would you call it? Patronizing.
And I think that the typical working
class person say who voted for Trump is
very, very sensitive to that.
And so they're much more concerned with
the 1% who are the cognitive elite than
they are the 1% who are the economic
elite because at least they think that's a
game they could play. So anyways, anyway,
it's also because there's caricature
is right of the 1% of the economically,
you just think of people that are in
these lofty positions that are in control
of the financial institutions.
But the 1% of the intellectually you
think of in terms of like some of the more
preposterous things you hearing out of
universities now and safe spaces and Oh
yeah, there's that too. There's
that too. There's no, well,
there's no appreciation on the part
of the intellectual elite for the
pathologies of rational of
rationalism. Right? I mean there's no,
there's nothing stupid or than a
smart person who went wrong. You know,
like you, you can Tang on, I've, I've
seen this in my clients, you know,
frequently,
like if I have a particularly smart
client who's particularly disordered in
their personality, that that's just,
that's often just, that's so difficult.
It's almost unimaginable because they're
so good at rationalizing. For example,
what is your approach to handling some
blind that who's like super intelligent
but yet completely their life is in
disarray? Well, you know, I'm, I usually,
I usually take a very practical approach.
Like, you know, we try to identify,
cause I start always
in my therapy practice,
I always start with behavioral
principles. It's like, okay,
well let's see if we can
identify a few areas, you know,
through negotiation that are really
causing you grief and misery. You know,
like what's, what's wrong with your
life as far as you're concerned.
And so that often takes a
lot of discussion and then
we might try to figure out
what's causing that. And that's often
very difficult to figure out too.
Cause it might be, jeez it might
be something physical, you know,
you might be sick in some way cause
depression is lots of depression is
autoimmune related and and anxiety
can be a side effect of all sorts of
physiological disorders or eating
improperly or sleeping badly or,
or not exercising, you know enough
to kind of keep yourself regulated.
She tried to figure out what,
what's causing it and then you try to
sketch out some possible solution that we
could both test. And then
with the, with the, uh,
with the more intelligent ones, you know,
often they can come up with all sorts
of reasons why none of this is going to
work or, or a thousand. Why? Yeah.
While usually a thousand reasons
why none of this is going to work.
And that with people like that,
sometimes it's useful to turn to
their dreams if, if they dream.
Because one of the things that's cool
about dreams is that even though they're
hard to interpret, they never lie.
And so sometimes you can take someone
who's hyper rational and the how of a
dream, and they'll tell you the dream.
And then you can work
through an interpretation,
which is a tricky business.
And the dream will tell them something
and there's just no denying it.
It's like, well, it's a statement
from nature. So what are you gonna do?
You're gonna pretend that that's
not the case. And also, so that's,
that's often extremely
useful. So, so, okay,
so while back to the equality issue,
so, okay, so here's what's happened.
So psychologists have, and
this is what's putting a tail,
not in the tail of the Scandinavians.
Psychologists have come to a pretty decent
agreement about standard personality
models, right? So there's extroversion,
neuroticism, agreeableness,
openness and conscientiousness. And they
look fairly stable cross-culturally.
And that was all done by
asking thousands of people,
hundreds and hundreds of questions
and then grouping them statistically.
So it was atheoretical.
Basically it took computational power
and statistics to find out that these are
how traits group. So I'm an extroverted,
people are sociable and happy and
neurotic people experience a fair bit of
negative emotion. So that's the positive
and negative emotion dimensions.
Agreeable people are
maternal and disagreeable,
people are competitive and there's a
fair bit of male female difference.
They're conscientious. People are
dutiful and industrious and orderly,
and the open people are creative. And
so those are your basic five dimensions.
Okay? So that's been established and
everyone more or less agrees on it.
Now maybe there's seven dimensions
and we've got a questionnaire that,
that that breaks the five down into
10 that's called understand myself.
Um, but, but basically there's good,
there's good consensus consent,
consensus on the five. Okay,
so now as soon as you have
the five basic traits,
you can ask some questions like,
well, do men and women differ?
And so what you do is you
just give the questionnaire.
You can either fill it out yourself or
have other people fill it out on your
behalf. So, and it could be a teacher,
could be a parent, you know, and,
and that's all being done.
And what you find is there are systematic
differences between men and women.
And the biggest differences are that
women experience more negative emotion and
that and that they're more
agreeable than men. So,
and that's born out by the
psychiatric evidence because um,
higher levels of negative emotion are
manifested in depression and anxiety and
women are diagnosed with higher levels
of depression and anxiety all around the
world. And with agreeableness,
that's also born out by
the clinical literature.
In some sense the medical literature
sociomedical literature because
disagreeable people are more likely to
be incarcerated because it's the best
predictor of being incarcerated even
though it's not a very good predictor.
And men are incarcerated at about a 10
to one rate compared to women and are
more likely to be antisocial
and conduct disorder.
So the personality differences are
mirrored in the sociomedical literature.
Okay, so the, so now, so there are
differences, but then there's a question,
are those differences a consequence of
socialization or are they biological?
And the answer to that is tricky because
how much something is social and how
much it is biological actually
depends on the social circumstances.
So while here's an example,
if you have a society where no one has
enough to eat and people are starving,
then there's a huge cultural
effect on people's intelligence.
Let's say that's mediated
by economic factors,
even though it's got a biological
origin, right? That's the starvation.
So the relationship between biology and
culture is actually partly culturally
dependent. So it makes it
complicated. But in any case,
here's how the scientists decided
to address this. They thought, well,
why don't we rank order countries by how
egalitarian their social policies are,
which you can do with a fair
degree of reliability. You know,
you put the countries where women are
second class citizens at the bottom,
and you'd put the Scandinavian
countries at the top.
You can get good reliability across
Raiders for how you would rate those
countries,
and then look at the magnitude of the
differences between men and women by the
egalitarian social policies.
And so then you'll find out,
and here's the hypotheses.
If the differences between
men and women are primary,
primarily social, then as
cultures become more egalitarian,
men and women will become more
alike. That's not what happened.
The opposite happened, the
more egalitarian the society.
And it turns out the richer the society
because that's also being discovered.
Now the more different
men and women become.
And so the differences are not huge.
So with agreeableness for example,
if you took the average man,
if you took a typical man and a typical
woman out of the population just
randomly and you had to bet that the
woman was more aggressive than the man,
you'd be wrong 60% of the time.
So there's quite a bit of overlap, right?
Cause you'd be right 40% of the time.
But the problem is is that a lot of
selection takes place at the extremes.
Maybe you're only concerned
about disagreeable people
when they become violent
and maybe it's only the one in 50 most
disagreeable person who's violent and
they're all men.
So you can have quite a bit of
similarity at the average level and big
differences at the extremes. And the
extremes is where people do things like,
like employment selection.
So the biggest difference that's been
discovered between men and women,
and this is the one that gets biggest
in the Scandinavian countries,
is interest.
Men are more interested in things and
women are more interested in people.
And it's a big difference. It's
one full standard deviation.
And so what that means
is that if you are a,
you would have to be more interested
in people than 85% of men to be as
interested in people as the
50th percentile a woman.
And you'd have to be more interested
in things than 85% of women to be as
interested in things as the
typical man. And what do you,
how do you define things?
[inaudible] okay. Gadgets, things.
[inaudible] things. Cars, car fuck.
Yeah, yeah. Tools. You know, technology,
right. STEM fields.
Because the other thing that's happened
is that the more egalitarian the
society, the fewer women go into the STEM
fields, the fewer. That's interesting.
Yeah. Okay. So, so now
this unravels in a big way.
It's like this is a hugely a relevant
issue politically because it means that
you cannot have equality of
opportunity and equality of outcome.
At the same time,
it's not possible because as you make
your society more egalitarian and you open
up the opportunity for
equality of outcome,
you increase how different men and
women are are and that changes their
occupational choice.
So if men are more interested in things
which they are by a substantial margin,
then way more of them are
going to be engineers.
Wouldn't that possibly support this
idea that an enforced model of,
of, of quality would allow
people to be themselves more?
I mean this is almost what you're
saying. Well that does, that is,
that is the optimistic
viewpoint Loomis. Well look,
it's so funny cause the Swedish foreign
minister told me to go crock clock climb
back under the rock that I came out from
under when I was in Scandinavia because
I was describing this,
these, this science.
I've read that, but I'm
not exactly sure why. Well,
she regards me as misogynist
because I think that there are,
because I think because I'd been putting
forward the evidence that there are
genuine differences between men and women,
but she should be held to accountable
for that because that's just a flippant
thing to say like you,
you, you, you should have,
especially in a position
of power like she's in,
you should have a very specific argument
saying like for a leader to have such
a, a base thing to say. Such
a crude, dumb thing to say.
Crawl back under the rock
that you came through.
I thought she was making
a joke about lobsters,
but I don't think she was the
lobsters go. Going to rocks.
I guess they do the growing cracks and
the bigger lobsters have better rocks.
That was another very interesting thing
and the GQ thing where the woman was
challenging you on your
neurobiology, your neurochemistry,
your understanding as
well. Hardly, hardly any,
hardly any psychologists understand
that serotonin is associated with
hierarchies. It's like a truism.
It's been known for 30 years so we can
definitely get back to that. But I, I'm,
I'm very curious about this because
this idea of enforced equality,
right?
Ensuring that there is such a high
emphasis played or placed on equality,
equality, that you have
the equal amount of men,
the equal amount of women
and the opportunities are
absolutely available as much
to women as they are to
men. This is enforced.
This creates an environment
where there's less resistance.
Now in an environment where
there's less resistance,
perhaps women don't feel as
compelled to say, I'll show you that.
That is what seems to happen. Well,
here's a Nikki look. Here's an example.
So there are fewer women mathematicians
in the, in the higher echelons, okay,
but here's something interesting about
mathematical ability. First of all,
it's very rare. So that's the
first thing to keep in mind.
Now it looks like if you look in junior
high that give mathematically gifted men
and males and females are
approximately as common. Now,
there's a little bit of debate about
that because there is some evidence that
may be at the very upper extremes.
There's a male advantage just like
there's a male disadvantage at the low end
because the male distribution
for intelligence might
be flatter and so that's
the greater Mary male
variability hypothesis.
There's been papers putting that
forward that had been retracted as a
consequence of pressure from
politically correct people.
Even though greater
mirror male variability is
actually quite common in the
animal kingdom for a variety of reasons,
men are more expendable that males
are more expendable in some ways.
Or you could say that males are more
likely to Purdue to pursue high risk,
high return strategies.
You can look at it either way and it's
certainly possible. In any case, the men,
the males in junior high who happened
to be mathematically gifted are less
likely to also be verbally gifted,
whereas that doesn't seem to
be the case for the females.
And so if you're a male math nerd,
then math is a pretty logical pathway
for you because you don't have as many
other options. Whereas if
you're female math nerd,
you have other options because
you're, you're less likely,
you're more likely to
also be verbally gifted.
And so that's enough to at
least in principle account
for some of the reason why
there are fewer women mathematicians
than men mathematicians.
They have other options. They have other
options and there's lots of complex,
there's lots of complex reasons like this.
And so we have this reflexive idea and
this is very much the case cause this is
like the core idea among the feminist
Neo Marxist types is that if there's
differences in outcome, that's
that's proof of prejudice.
And that's support for the idea
of the patriarchal tyranny.
And that's like the core Axiom of the
radical left is the patriarchal tyranny as
far as I'm concerned. That's, that's
God for them. The patriarchal tyranny.
It's like, well,
if it turns out that many
of these differences in
outcome between men and women
aren't a consequence of the
patriarchal tyranny, in fact,
even get bigger when you
reduce the tyrannical aspect
of the patriarch and even
the patriarchal aspect to it,
then it makes that theory not only wrong,
but opposite of the truth, which
is the worst kind of wrong.
And so, you know,
if men are more likely to Purdue
pursue careers in the STEM fields,
which seems to be the case under
conditions of optimal freedom for men and
women,
then that's going to drive
income disparities because
the STEM fields pay more
and they pay more. Partly
because they're scalable,
like it's really hard to scale
care for people. You know,
like if you work in a daycare, you're
going to care for three infants,
you're not going to care for 50
cause you can't, it's not scalable.
But if you're like a software
designer, it's infinitely scalable.
And so there's,
there's a much wider range of possible
of possibility for generating much
larger,
much larger income pools and much
larger pools of wealth. You know,
and men are also more
likely to work longer hours.
And if you work 10% longer
hours, you make 40% more money,
there's a nonlinear return on.
That's a good thing for everybody who's
listening to know if you have a job,
you want to be the guy or the woman
who's working that extra 10% because the
return on that is nonlinear. So
that's a really useful thing to know.
Men are more likely to work outside,
they're more likely to work
in dangerous businesses.
They're more likely to run
full time businesses rather
than part-time businesses
and they're more likely to move
in pursuit of their career goals.
And that all contributes to
differences in and and in,
in among Uber drivers there they make
7% more money cause they drive faster so
and so anyway. So that's not good though.
Well I'll know but it's a high risk.
The high risk, high return issue,
right? It's a pattern mail. The common,
it's more risk.
There's more risk in it so there's more
return as long as you don't get hurt.
And I think that's a pretty common
male pattern is there's more risk,
there's more return as
long as you don't get hurt.
Problems seems to be when
discussing these things in any way,
way a romanticizing or a glorifying
male behavior or putting any emphasis
whatsoever on there being
a positive aspect to a lot
of the things that we think
of as being negative, like
aggression or ambition or, or,
or competition and competition
amongst men is fine.
Competition with men against women
is often thought of as cruel. Yeah.
Well that, yes. Well and, and,
and there's a certain amount of reason
for that as well because obviously
physical competition is, it's
easy for that to border on. Cruel.
This is why we were talking,
we were talking before the show
that instead of calling people,
men and women when referring
to like, cause there's,
there's this very
disturbing, in my opinion,
trend of transgender women entering into
these competitions now with women who
are biologically female and dominating
them. And that instead of calling people,
men and women dispense with them, you
can be a man or a woman to say, yeah,
you can be a man or
woman. That's your choice.
And you can change it whenever you
want. So you're a man or a woman.
And that's your choice. But
we're going to have a new rule,
which is that if you have an X,
Y chromosome, so you're an X,
Y person or an X X person, than
if you're an X, X person, X,
Y person, you don't get to engage in
physical combat with an X, Y person,
man or woman X, X person mass.
Yeah. How would that, if you're X,
Y you can't engage in
physical combat with X, X, X,
Ys cannot hit X X's. How's
that? And maybe they can't, um,
run in co running contests against them
and maybe they can't play tennis against
them, not within. And maybe
that's just reasonable.